[Music]
I'm super romantic I'm super mushy
Priyanka Chopra beaming talking about
love amid her budding relationship with
Nick Jonas Priyanka says why not too
over-the-top romantic gestures you know
when you love someone I care about
somebody making them feel special and
giving them attention is the most
important thing but there is a key to
stealing her heart I don't I'm not the
chocolates and chocolates and flowers
kind of girl I mean no I love gift of
course I love gifts but which curl
doesn't but I think it's the it's the
written word that always makes me really
happy like something written down a
letter or no do not ever get me
chocolates and flowers and when it comes
to marriage the thirty-five year old
says she's open to it I love the idea of
getting married I totally you want to
get married at some point and I don't
think marriage makes you smaller or
bigger more feminist or not et was with
Priyanka at the vote by Saks event in
the Hamptons where she gave us her
essentials for the perfect summer night
wine good wine not just any one good
wine great clothes comfortable beautiful
clothes and amazing company you cannot
come to the Hamptons with bad company
and the key to her summer glow feel my
most beautiful when I'm happy
you